there's a bunch of stories we can choose
i'm choosing this one because sometimes
we need a little innate innanity in
hannity yeah this is from fox news
nicole hannah jones goes off on tipping
as a legacy of slavery deletes the tweet
hannah jones clashed with historian phil
magnus over the history of tipping well
so here's what happened right everything
is slavery turned out well hopefully you
can also just stop at nicole hannah
jones clashes with historian there's
there's two two big things happened
which yeah that's actually kind of two
big things happened from her tweet from
within the crit community within the
woke community one was that she's right
and the other was that she's racist so
let me read what you said first she said
tipping is a legacy of slavery and if
it's not optional then it shouldn't be a
tip but simply included in the bill have
you ever stopped to think why we tip
like why tipping is a practice in the
u.s and almost nowhere else actually
tipping is widely practiced all over the
world but uh what some people
immediately said it's not huge in asia
it's not huge in asia europe well it
actually it was offensive in in asia in
asia yeah it's it's considered like a
bribe almost well well so uh in some
countries the way we would consider when
when you have bad service you put extra
money down saying you need help do
better like you need my charity because
your business is doing bad so it's
considered like on a front to their
honor like they they told you what it
cost for their service they provided you
a service to give them more is to imply
they're not doing well and they need
help but uh it's it's kind of changing
in a lot of the or that they want to
fire more to give you a higher level of
help right in the in the west it's like
demanded anyway but here's what happened
first many people agreed with her they
were like
you know the stereotype is that black
people don't tip well or whatever and
her that's what they were pointing out
like her point is you making someone
give money for a bad tip is racist and
that's where the stereotype i don't know
if you said this explicitly but people
were saying the stereotype is that
people who are black experience bad
service because of racism
that's why they don't i see that's why
there's a stereotype about not tipping
is because they're mistreated for being
black other people said you're literally
reinforcing a stereotype about about you
know these diners so my point in all
this is honestly i have no idea
i have no opinion because i've not been
a server or experienced yet i can just
say no matter what you do it's racist
even when you're nicole hannah jones
she's the 16-19 project right yeah
even she's racist so there's no out all
of you everyone at all times even the
person who claims everyone else's race
is racist too yeah and so uh i don't
know what the aristocrats or something
well tim you're obviously the wrong
person to talk about this i mean you're
so bad at diners you can't even get a
reservation at one yeah how come you
didn't get a reservation for that diner
or anything yeah it's so crazy right
yeah i guess you can't isn't it the
weirdest thing in the world to me dude i
was aware is the weirdest thing in the
world it is to me i was a waiter for
about a decade on and off what about
what about you emily were you ever no i
was a camp counselor
i worked at a bakery so like bakery
slash deli so we served food but it
wasn't like with seating we did the tip
seating everything i yeah i had one time
i had a couple of older women left me a
nickel just so i knew that they didn't
forget to tip me
that was insulting that was when it was
early and there was a there's an old uh
30 rock episode where i forget the
character's name but um and it's john
lithgow's character and he goes he goes
i'm going to revolutionize the the
practice of tipping i always thought
this was great where he goes and he he
the weight the wage i think it's a wager
she comes down and he go he just plops a
stack of ones on the table and he goes
do you see this right here this
represents your potential tip now
if this
if the surface is good the tip will grow
but if it is poor the tip will shrink
the final number is up to you wow you
make it a game show it was great yeah i
thought that was great a lot of waiters
and waiters i've always thought of
actually doing it they didn't they took
by the way if you tried that in real
life i'm pretty sure your food would get
spat in very quickly nope not everybody
put a 100 you know 100 bill or you know
10 hundreds on the table and say i got a
thousand bucks you know or however many
ready and waiting for you as the service
declines the hundreds get removed so
let's see how much you can make at the
end of the day i don't think they'll
spit in your food i'll cheat code for
flights tip your weight uh tip your uh
services
okay when you first come on totally um
go to the starbucks get like
10 gift card 15 gift card right there in
you know while you're while you're
waiting to get out in the terminal just
walk on even if you only give it to one
right they'll tell the others and they
they know where you are right and i
guarantee you you're playing your flight
and when you go to the bar tip the
bartender before you start ordering
drinks yeah because then they love you
all right what do you think would happen
if you were sitting on a plane and like
this the flight tenant came over and
said sir i'm sorry you have to wear a
mask you just handed a 100 bill instead
and they're like oh i'm sorry here you
go and like you know i'm sorry they need
to wear your mask right right when i was
waiting tables uh i george watched a lot
of other a lot of other servers would
have been frank this thing you're saying
that black families were would not tip
well and i hated it and so i did a
stereotype yeah i one time i had like a
family of like five or something i think
i'm remembering this relatively clearly
and they're black people i don't even
think no no their skin was like darker
than mine whatever the hell that means
i'm i'm not white by the way uh i'm pink
uh some of these people i was like i
don't care i'm not playing this game i
gave them the best service i could and
they didn't leave me a good tip it was
really bad and i just thought they
didn't have enough money i didn't care
it wasn't racist i don't care you know
if you can't afford it you can't afford
it you pay it's a tip it's extra it's
not meant you know yep my issue is
that you get money on the left saying if
you can't afford to tip you can't afford
to go out to eat
and then i'm just like you know i was
thinking about that and i was like if
you can't afford an electric car you
can't afford to drive there you go right
so all the environmentalists who are
like
gas is destroying the planet that's my
response to them you know look
climate change is bad
if you want to enact policies over
climate change then you got to put up or
shut up so don't come to me and be like
we got to change the wages because you
know if you can't afford a tip and i'm
like okay well then like don't come to
me and say you have a problem with
carbon emissions when you're literally a
component of the problem
choose not to be a part of that problem
there's no coherence when i was in ohio
waiting tables i was making two dollars
and 13 cents an hour at minimum that was
the minimum server wage because you
expect to get tips because you're
supposed to get it it's woven into the
process now so we can undo that but then
went to california i got minimum wage 12
bucks an hour and then tips on top of it
that's a california law
um
i guess we could
no i i just they're they they the super
chat the daily wire wrote about me we're
making a big circle here
they've already oh that was fast
absolutely fantastic brilliant one of
the funniest commercials i think you
might have actually said all that stuff
yeah i did say all that stuff yeah here
here i second daily while i was here i
haven't seen the commercial i was
talking to some of them it's another
glass so now they're going to write an
article tim poole raves about the taylor
wires
of the daily watch and here's media bias
in a nutshell what is the byline there
the author of the story his name is tim
they know what they were doing yeah tim
okay
i gotta i gotta wonder hold on to
inception
i'm wondering if like uh jeremy or
banner or somebody the daily wire saw my
video this morning and then came in and
said can someone write this up because
it's free advertising for us so let's
just shout out absolutely yeah or or
maybe this tim mead's guy was like hey
did you see tim did a video can i write
this up and they were like
yeah i will groom with that thing on air
if you sent me one yeah let's do it
groom with uh well jeremy's racist
yeah
shave just sounds like some q a stuff
don't well
and if you get caught hopefully you get
uh judge kataji brown jackson that's
nice
oh so
she'll give you a lighter a lighter
sentence thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you